جذور الحرب في الدنباس بدات منذ العام
2014 منذ اجتياح وضم اقليم شبه جزيره
القرم لنرى معا هذه الجذور هذه هي شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا العام 2014
وتقول بانها تابعه لها تاريخيا فلنرى
التطورات حسب الترتيب الزمني العام 2013
لمن يتذكر هناك مظاهرات مواليه
للديمقراطيه ولاوروبا في ساحه ميدان في
كييف وادت الى سقوط النظام والرئيس
الموالي لروسيا في العام 2014 في الاول من
اذار مارس مجموعه فاجنر دخلت على خط
الازمه لاول مره واللعبت دورا في شبه
جزيره ضم شبه جزيره القرم وايضا مسانده
مطالب الانفصاليين في الدومباس في في
لوهان
تم ضم اقليم الدون باس والذي
نراه هنا ومتمثلا في
اقليميه ادونسك ولهانسك وهما اقليماني
يتميزان بغالبيه من الرسفون والروسيين
ايضا الذين يتمتعون بالثقافه وباللغه
الروسيه ثم في هذا السياق بين العامين
والالفين كان هناك هدوء حذر في ظل ازمه
هذه الدونباس
المستفحله وفي العام 2021 تطورت الامور في
الثمن من يونيو حزيران باعلان الولايات
المتحده نيتها ضمه اوكرانيا الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي هنا توترت الامور لتخلص في العام
2022 الى اجتياح روسيا الى اوكرانيا
لتغيير النظام بسرعه
واع
باستقلال الاقليم دوناتسك
في ثم تطور اخر في العام 2022 بين 23
والسابع والعشرين يوليو ايلول سبتمبر من
هذا العام نظم استفتاء ثم
بموجبه او ضمت بموجبه المناطق الاربعه
الى خرسون
وزابوريتشيا تحت السياده الروسيه الان هذه
السياده الروسيه التي تريد الضمه المناطق
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه الى السياده
الروسيه لكن هذا الضم يبقى غير معترف به
على الساحه الدوليه